you think I killed her
the lady was bad news so that makes it
okay I killed her did you the head of
course is Harrison for to the 1990 movie
presumed innocent it's based on the best
selling novel by author Scott Turow
the book is one of his 10 bestsellers
and they've been translated into more
than 40 different languages they sold
more than 30 million copies worldwide
today he's out with his first new book
in four years
it's called testimony about a prosecutor
who moves abroad to investigate a
refugee camps disappearance during the
Bosnian war scott turow we welcome you
back to the tape
Dale thank you here they're describing
after four years we're glad to have you
back sir
testimony a tour de force of collapsing
perceptions it took you four years
because you were doing a lot of research
on this why I did a lot of research I
went to Europe three times I spent a
week in The Hague which is a wonderful
city and a different kind of week in
Bosnia which is also a remarkable place
what did you want to tell on this one um
you know I iced in turns I just I wanted
to go someplace a little different and I
thought that frankly the International
Criminal Court is not something that's
well understood in the United States and
therefore made I thought an interesting
setting for a legal thriller where'd you
get the idea from I was had I was at a
reception in in The Hague in Holland
which was the capital or one of the
capitals at the American ambassadors
house and there was a group of American
lawyers who worked in The Hague and they
were all around me going you know you've
got to write a book about this place
this place is amazing the back stories
and the back channels and the cases
themselves you know and usually when
people are saying that to you it's like
how you know Antilles antique base
disappeared yeah this is just what I
thought wow that's an interesting idea
and I always held on to it so who did
you create as your main character the
main character is a guy named Bill tan
Boon midlife crisis although for reasons
that he doesn't quite understand is
given up his marriage as job finally
his country and gone off to the hague to
investigate the disappearance of these
400 Roma gypsies no but news that what
you say about him being a successful
middle-aged man suddenly single is like
being the waterboy for the football team
who finds a magic Genie has turned him
into the prom king yes he said you know
the bills there's another side to bills
life of course man since he's a single
male and he discovers that he's he has
all the magical powers that he wished he
had when he was 17 and watching us all
today a tour de force of the collapsing
perceptions so nobody lays crushes
nobody is quite who they seem to be yeah
and you know Bill of course is led
astray in several different ways
both by witnesses and in his personal
life and and yet it's it's like a set of
you know Chinese boxes things keep
opening outward and it twists and turns
but it all makes sense so sometimes
writers do something where you didn't
see it coming we go where's that coming
out of left field that is not what you
do in this book as complicated and
layered as it is is that important it's
very Amin one of the things I was proud
of when I finished the book was that I
felt exactly what you're saying that it
really does all come together and it has
both a unified story in a unified
meaning are you still practicing law I
do a little bit I'm a partner in a big
international firm called Denton's and I
always have a case or two going so when
I get back from the book 2rl dig into
something new yeah they don't look a
lawyer yeah yes they don't look at you
and go off your book tour decided to
come to work today
it's you know it's a deal that's worked
for everybody so yeah 1890 and so they
let me write and practice lon
you know and I still really enjoy being
a lawyer did when you get outside of
your comfort zone where are you what do
you do
are we talking about as a lawyer as a
writer both and a man a writer and as a
man less boys yeah um you know I've
renewed my life about 10 years ago and
it's been wonderful adventure well you
know I had I had a marriage that ended
and you know put me on a new course and
for me it's been tonic it's been
revitalizing I'm remarried now my was
astir i was in the green sister always
in the green he's lovely yeah you know I
I there's a lot of pain involved in that
for everybody
certainly my kids and if a great
relationship now with my ex but it
sounds like that might have fed who bill
is it certainly fed who bill really game
we cannot we cannot walk away there are
a lot of references in that book about
divorce
very well done how do you hear I go
north background right thank you so much
thanks guys and testimony is on sale now